right now we're facing the biggest Ebola
outbreak we've ever seen in history more
than 2,000 people have died that's more
than the total number of people who have
ever died from Ebola since the first
recorded outbreak in 1976 and the bulk
of the deaths have happened within the
last month so things aren't getting
better there are a couple things that
have helped this outbreak really spin
out of control and one is the fact that
the response just wasn't fast enough
it wasn't until August that the World
Health Organization declared this a
public health emergency and that was
five months after the first
international spread in the past Ebola
outbreaks tended to be in really rural
remote areas and this time it wound up
in a border region in West Africa where
people might cross the border for work
or they might cross to go to the market
with that you get international spread
this is a region of Africa that's never
seen Ebola so they didn't have the
awareness about what this disease was in
the population these are also regions of
Africa that have some of the lowest
literacy rates so that made mounting a
public health information campaign that
all the more difficult and there was
fear there was mistrust of health
professionals people in this part of the
world they're used to being cared for by
their families when they're sick in the
home and in this case they have to be
ripped from their homes and put into
containment facilities and these are
places that have some of the weakest and
poorest health systems in the world in
some of the hospitals there are days
where they just don't have gloves gowns
and masks because of this there have
been health care workers who have just
walked off the job they don't want to
put themselves at risk anymore and I
don't know if you can really blame them
in Liberia people are taking their
family members to the hospitals but
they're being turned away there are no
free beds for Ebola treatment in the
country right now so as a result we
bolas going back into the community and
spreading further we could look at this
epidemic as a kind of warning that we
need
robust global health systems especially
in a world that's increasingly connected
not something that we don't have now and
that's one of the reasons why we've seen
things get so out of control in this
outbreak
you